the answer you'll get from this  generator this my generation is I want  to change the world Gary in fact what I  came to learn is they want to be the  type of person that's known for changing  the world they want the admiration  that's right they saw the audience right  and they want that feeling the money the  fame the accolades the blue check the  followers the fun I understand the  problem with all the things I just  mentioned is there a vulnerability to  your own happiness if it's not balanced  the why if you like love the [ __ ] like I  don't understand sports cards and the  feeling of going that fast that's not me  if you enjoy that that's phenomenal when  I talk about materialistic things I talk  about makeup for insecurity you know how  people burn out they're working till two  in the morning to buy the expensive car  to use it to close their insecurity to  get the affirmations or their friends  that system's broke it won't work